guten abend herr breiter und hatte
gerade die bilder gesehen sieben mussten
als partyveranstalter einige
veranstaltungen schon absagen wegen
krone sind sie wütend wenn es solche
bilder sehen mir blutet das herz wenn
ich so was wäre denn ich meine wir sind
alle im lotter und drin
es gibt verbot für für jegliche
großveranstaltungen mit mehreren
hunderten leuten und naja die
eventbranche liegt eben am boden und
dann sind natürlich solche bilder nicht
gerade hilfreich wenn man clubs sterben
sie wenn man die veranstaltungsbranche
sterben sie dann fragt man sich schon
was ich jetzt hier sehe auch an den
bildern
es sind schon viele menschen aufeinander
ohne maske das ist nicht hilfreich für
die für die lobbyarbeit die gerade
betrieben werden muss damit kultur
wieder irgendwie erlebbar gemacht wird
und bild liegt ja auch eine
zeugenaussage vor von einem partygast er
gesagt hat dass mitten in der nacht
immer wieder neue leute nachkommen und
die dann eben nicht mehr getestet wurden
da war das testzentrum schon vollkommen
abgebaut für wie gefährlich halten sie
das naja ich kann dazu nichts sagen ich
war nicht dort von außen betrachte die
gesagt sehe ich nur die bilder die da
sind und die verheißen jetzt im jetzigen
locker und eben nichts gutes ich meine
es in bilder eigentlich die vor der 100
seiten stattfinden können aber so da
drinnen eben nicht und nicht mein es
wurden kreatives gemacht wurde jetzt
hier gesagt ob da jetzt dann bei
nachgemacht werden so wenig weiß ich
nicht aber es ist eine super gefährliche
sache klar
und jetzt muss man natürlich auch an
ihrer stelle ein bisschen in die zukunft
blicken auch wenn das schwerfällt was
glauben sie denn als experte wie könnte
dann eine party aussehen in zeiten von
corona naja ich war zuerst mal freuen
wir uns alle und sehen wir auch einen
kleinen lichtblick darin dass es einen
impfstoff geben soll geben wird die
kommt die konzepte die die da gemacht
werden müssen sich daran anpassen wie
die situation dann eben wenn auch
momentan ist man jetzt musst du erstmal
impfstoff her damit kultur wieder
erlebbar gemacht werden
und das schlimmste ist ja ich meine wir
menschen sind wir alles soziale wesen
und soziale kontakte müssen stattfinden
deswegen müssen wir schauen dass wir
ich jetzt also nur die hygiene konzepte
von jetzt betrachten die komplett im
block down jetzt auch nicht mehr
stattfinden können sondern wir müssen
gucken was können wir tun das können wir
machen in verbindung mit impfstoffen
dass wir wieder kultur erleben können
und wenn ich mir ein workshop zum
ansehen
wir machen große stadien events und wenn
ich mir vorstelle dass da irgendwie noch
ein drittel der leute reinkommen dürfte
dann würde auch so dieses gesamtgefühl
nicht passieren
dann würden wir auch kein workshops und
veranstaltungen von daher ich weiß es
nicht wo die reise hingeht aber ich
denke mir die politik und die
wissenschaft ist hier sehr gefragt und
wir unterstützen das in allen möglichen
dingen auch mit hygiene konzepten und so
weiter das esskultur wieder erlebbar
gemacht wird mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren